what is love it is a
difficult term to define as
its application is very broad
i can like jogging
i can like a book a movie i can
like a cutlet i can like my
wife
but there is  a big difference between
a cutlet and my wife for example
is that if I value the cutlet
the cutlet on the other hand in return she does
not value me
whereas my wife she calls me
the star of her life only one  other
desiring consciousness therefore can
constitute me as a desirable being
that I know and this is why
love can be defined more
precisely as being the desire to be
desired sweet the eternal problem
of love
how to become  and how to remain
desirable then the answer to this problem
the individual found it in the past by
submitting his life to the rules of the
community
he had a precise role to play according to
his sex his age his social status
it was enough for him to take it for  to be
valued and loved by t  all of her
community
think of the young girl who must remain
chaste before marriage
think of the younger son who owes obedience
to the eldest son who himself owes
obedience to the patriarch
only here is a phenomenon that
began from the 13th century but especially from
the renaissance in the West  which
caused the greatest identity crisis
in the history of humanity
this phenomenon is modernity we
can roughly summarize it by a triple
process first a process of
rationalization of scientific research
which accelerates progress
technical
then a process of
political democratization which developed the rights of
the individual and finally a process of
rationalization of the
economic production and liberalization of the
commercial exchanges
these three intertwined processes
completely destroyed all the traditional reference marks
of the Western societies
the consequence for the  he individual is
radical the individual is now free
to value or devalue  ser such
attitude
of such choices such object but suddenly his
person herself is confronted with this
same freedom as others to value him
or devalue him to put it
differently
my value formerly I assured it by
submitting to the traditional authorities
now it  is listed on the stock exchange
on the free market of individual desires
i trade my value every day hence
the anguish of contemporary man his
obsession
am i desirable how much
how many people will love me and how
does t- respond  it is to this anxiety that
hysterically accumulates the
symbols of desirability
this accumulation I call it
with others the seduction capital it is on
the seduction capital that
our consumer society is in fact largely based,
we say to  this statement
about consumption that our time is
materialistic but it is false if we
accumulate objects it is to
communicate with other minds
it is to make us love  two
seduce them
nothing less materialistic nothing more
sentimental than a teenager who buys
a pair of brand new jeans who
rips it at the knee because he wants to please
jennifer consumerism is not
materialism
it is rather the  matter swallowed up
sacrificed in the name of the god of love or rather
in the name of capital seduction then
from this observation on current love
how to think about love in
future years
we can consider two hypotheses the
first consists of betting on an
accentuation of this process  of
narcissistic capitalization what form
this accentuation will take is very
hard to say because it largely depends on
social
and technical innovations which are by definition not
difficult to predict but one can for
example imagine a
dating website where a bit like  with
points this maize 1 we work with
seduction capital points that vary
according to my age my height-to-weight ratio my
diploma my salary or the  number of
clicks accumulating on my profile
we can also imagine a
chemical treatment of the romantic breakup which
weakens the feeling of attachment
there is already a program on
the mtv channel where teachers of
seduction treat the heartache
as a  illness these teachers are
called pick-up artists so
artists in French it's easy these
artists and then pick-ups and lifting
but not just any age
girl lifting so they are girl lifting artists
and they call  they
call heartache one it is it is in
english it is a suffix which means
infections of which when it is we could
translate its part infections of the unique
it is not a bit disgusting and in fact
for pick ups  artist to
fixate on someone in love and well it's a
waste of time it's squandered
its seduction capital and therefore we must
eliminate it as a disease like an
infection
we can still consider a
romantic use of the ca  rte genomics
we have it we will carry it each on our own
then we would show it as a business
card to check if seduction
can not lead to reproduction
so of course this race for
seduction like any fierce competition
will produce two major disparities
of narcissistic satisfaction and therefore
also a lot of loneliness a lot of
frustration
then we will have to expect that
modernity itself, which is at the origin
of the seduction capital, will be called into
question, I am thinking in particular of
communitarian reactions of the neo-fascist type or
religious but good such a future is
not inevitable
another voice may be possible to
think about love but how
how to give up the hysterical demand
to be valued and well by becoming
aware of my
nullity and yes I am useless but reassure
you too
but if we are we are all
zero it is quite easy to demonstrate
this nullity since to be
valued I ask the  other than he
desires me therefore it is that I have no
value in myself I have no value
in itself
we all have
finally we all pretend to have an
idol we all pretend to be an
idol  for someone but in fact we
are all impostors and a bit
like the one who passes as an
indifferent lord in the street when he has
planned everything so that
all eyes are on him so I
think that becoming aware of  this of
this general imposture which
concerns all of us passive irene in
love relationships it is because I
want to be adored to the end of my
nails justified in all my choices
that there is a hysteria of seduction
and suddenly  I want to appear perfect so
that the other person even I want him to be
perfect so that he can reassure me about my
value and this gives couples obsessed
with performance and who will
leave each other precisely at the slightest counter-
performance then at the  opposite of this
attitude
I invoke tenderness  love
as tenderness what
is tenderness it is time to it is to accept the
weaknesses of the loved one
but it is not a question of turning into a
sad couple of being caregivers 1
c  is not terrible there is on the contrary a
lot of charm a lot of joy in
the tenderness I think in particular a type
of humor which unfortunately very little practiced and
which is a kind of poetry of the
assumed awkwardness I think of
self-mockery for a  couple who are no
longer maintained supported by the
constraints of tradition I think that
self-mockery is one of the best
ways to last
[Music]